let's kick off with those GDP figures
the growth figures that we saw released
at seven o'clock this morning we weren't
expecting them to be very good we're
expecting them to show that growth in
the economy was flat lining but they
were much worse than that a contraction
of 0.3 percent how worried are you about
that yeah we've seen a dip for March but
over the period we've actually seen an
increase of 0.1 so it sort of shows two
two particular parts and if we compared
to where we were last year the bank of
England was predicting uh recession and
job losses so we've got improvement over
the period but I accept obviously for
March we've actually got that particular
uh Point as well so look these are
challenging times there's there's no
doubt but we do have a priority of
growing the economy and of course any
signs of growth rusts are important when
there was a recession predicted in the
year before and I think everyone knows
you know we're going through an
incredibly tough International time
right now but it's important for us that
we actually stay the course we've got
our priorities in place uh it's
important that we have inflation manage
economy well and we believe that will
get the country through so we're
absolutely focused uh on the policies
that we've been set out by the
chancellor in the budget you talk about
that pledge to halve inflation are you
confident that Rishi sunac will still
achieve that given that the bank of
England now thinks that inflation is
going to be higher than it had thought
it's increased its forecast now and says
that inflation will be at five percent
at the end of the year not four yes as I
was going to say they've they've they've
made the point they believe it would be
at five percent we are still committed
and we believe that that halving of
inflation uh will be delivered by the
end of the year that's a commitment we
have that's why it's particularly
important that we have pay uh restraint
food inflation is particularly high but
the supermarkets and retailers met with
government representatives and they're
confident that those prices will start
to come down there's a bit of a six to
nine month lag in the process so that
should all lead towards and government
measures such as the energy guarantee
lead to a better sort of two percentage
Point drop in inflation and of course
was freezing fuel Duty also assists as
well so there are certain government
measures that will help towards
controlling inflation and they're also
the sort of international impacts which
we hope will lessen as well what about
resolving strikes and the impact that
would have on the economy and the ons in
this release of the latest growth
figures has has said that strikes have
been a factor in this contraction in
growth in March there's another strike
going on today the aslef train drivers
Union is walking out today you obviously
transport Minister how far away is that
dispute from resolution well we hope it
will be resolved we have facilitated an
offer which has been put to the leaders
of the two trade unions and we're asking
for them to put that offer to their
members it's a very similar offer to one
that was put by the rmt to the members
that worked on network rail which was
the
um the the results of a lot of the
industrial action of last year and their
members overwhelmingly overwhelmingly
accepted that offer so our feeling is if
it was good enough to we put to the
members who work for Network rail why
not being good enough to put to the
members who work on the trains then we
hope if that were the case it would be
accepted and we'd move on well as left
has called the four percent payoff
risible and obviously unacceptable well
it was it's a four percent offer for
this year four percent offer for last
year and if you consider the average uh
wage of a train driver is just short of
sixty thousand pounds for a 35-hour base
week this would take the pay up to 65
000 pounds and and these are train
drivers that have received a 39 increase
in their wages since 2011. it's a
well-paid job it will continue to be
even more well paid if they were to put
that offer to their members what do you
make of the fact that the two rail
strikes today by as left tomorrow by the
rmt coincide with people trying to get
to the Eurovision Song Contest in
Liverpool at the two unions say that it
wasn't deliberately targeted but what's
your reaction to the timing of it well I
mean the unions have picked not just
Eurovision but the FA Cup Final with
both Manchester teams coming down to
London for that showcase and the Derby
so they either don't have a particularly
good sporting or events calendar or has
been done deliberately to try and
Ratchet up the disruption for passengers
it's particularly challenging with
regard to Eurovision because we're
hosting that competition on behalf of
Ukraine there are contingencies in place
our coach operators have really stood up
to this will deliver but it's a huge
shame to Target our sort of cultural and
sort of sporting uh events particularly
if those events we're hosting for our
friends over in Ukraine sticking with
Railways um you the government announced
yesterday that transpennine Services
would go into government hands
temporarily what evidence is there that
services will improve in government
hands well this is a reset moment it's
an opportunity for us to change the
operator and have a new start we hope
that means better relations with
Workforce and of course passengers But
ultimately most of the matters were
related to agreements that the unions
were unwilling to work towards I'm sorry
to say so there are a number of drivers
who are retiring there's a certain age
average about 53 for a train driver many
are retiring to try and put new drivers
in place takes about 18 months to train
and normally you need to rely on
overtime to be able to have people to be
able to train up the drivers and since
December 2021 the unions had refused to
allow the workforce to work overtime so
that's caused a huge issue so my message
is this is a reset moment we have
listened and we've looked at a new
operator as being the Right Way Forward
we're now asking for the unions to play
their part and allow the workforce to
work in a more flexible manner that will
really help bolster the performance but
if you're relying on over time to run a
railway smoothly you've got a staffing
shortage haven't you've got a staffing
problem how will that get better and
government has well this is the thing
that's always fascinating to me I used
to chair the transport select committee
before okay in the rail Minister and the
the pro process of change in rail is
very very slow so you know most
institutions you just ask an individual
if they wanted to work overtime and they
say yes no here we have a whole series
of agreements and what's happened over
the years is the minimum number of hours
as reduced in terms of the weekly hour
and so that's now down to 35 hours and
then many instances if you want coverage
for someone that's called in sick or to
train up drivers you have to actually
rely on overtime if the overtime
agreement is banned for the whole the
workforce you can't then rely on that
with Avanti which was another operator
that came into the spotlight we were
able to get more drivers trained up
they're an extra hundred and that
allowed us to put an extra 40 of the
timetable back on but we don't have that
same ability with TP so what we're
calling for with the unions is we've
listened we've looked at the situation
we believe it does need a change it's a
reset moment for us can we now have the
same type of flexibility and positive
look from the unions get these
agreements entered into the most
generous overtime agreement of all
operators would be there if it would get
signed that would allow individuals to
decide if they want to work above their
35 hours transparent Express will be the
the fourth company to be taken into
government hands the model just isn't
working isn't it so this sorry why don't
you renationalize the railways if that's
if you you're saying that being in
government hands will improve things
look we're very flexible we have four
operators within the operator of Last
Resort the other three have not been
down to Performance they've been down to
financial issues in terms of the ability
of that operator to run the service this
is the first one where we've had to look
at it from a performance basis equally
with Avanti where there are the same
calls we resisted those because we could
see Improvement in the service the
cancellation rate has gone down from 13
at the beginning of the year uh to just
above one percent in terms of anti-fold
for cancellation so that's an operator
that stays within the private sector
that's delivering so we're not operating
on the basis of Dogma we do it on the
basis of what we think is right in the
circumstances but we do need flexibility
and reform so that we can run a
seven-day Railway we still have to ask
drivers to volunteer to work on a Sunday
that's no way for us to run a railway
and that's why we need reform as well as
the pay rise okay well and I have one
other question about the Eurovision song
contest president zielinski is reported
to have wanted to to address the contest
but has been blocked from doing that
because of fears that it would
politicize the event what's your take on
that should he be allowed to address it
so that's a matter for the organizers
but it's not a decision that's been
taken by the government by the BBC or by
anyone in Liverpool it said sort of
European broadcasters pool and they have
as I understand it a very strict
requirement that there can't be anything
that they deem as political look our
commitment to Ukraine is there we're
hosting it on their behalf where their
friends we're really proud to do so and
that's why I'm very disappointed to sit
here as the rail Minister and find that
not everyone is willing to play their
part would you have liked to have seen
president zielinski be allowed to
address the contest look I can see where
you're taking me here I always love to
see President zielinski because I think
he's an absolute hero and leader to his
Nation but matters for the Eurovision
are matters for the Eurovision rather
than me